better than I deserve what's up in your
world okay I'll have an extremely
embarrassing question to ask and it's
not embarrassing for me it's actually
embarrassing for my parents okay how do
I tell them that I'm not going to fund
their stupidity for example today my
father called me I'm just to give you
some background I am 25 my husband and I
are expecting our first child we are
going to be relocating to a different
state and my parents are expecting me to
pay for their airline tickets when they
come down to visit and recently my
father today dropped the bomb on me that
I need to help him buy a vehicle that
because I wrecked his seven years ago I
mean I didn't wreck it I just took the
side mirror off seven years ago so your
parents obviously struggle with
boundaries don't they Wow
I mean it's it's completely
inappropriate to ask someone to buy a
car seven years after they knocked the
mirror off I know it's totally in is
doubly inappropriate if it's your
daughter
it's triple inappropriate if she's the
mother of your grandchildren for
goodness sakes and in addition to that
then you're supposed to pay for them to
come visit you what is wrong with these
people well the worst thing is after I
had back there eating my dad's vehicle
on I was in college I was only working
weekends back home and I had to pay for
the damages and I gave him $2,000 which
back then was like my entire life and I
found out that he had the insurance paid
for it and he used that money to book a
vacation which he canceled so he lost
that money and he didn't tell it like my
mother when they come to you asking for
you to do inappropriate things with
money yes what's wrong with them they're
just really stupid and I put them I gave
them an FPU membership and they started
going and now they're like oh well you
know dave says we need to start saving
money and it would be so much more
helpful if you gave us some money
because you and your husband
I admit we're blessed I'm a stay-at-home
wife my husband works in very hard I
have so much respect for him but we like
I can't I want to tell them no but they
don't hear me when I tell them no and my
husband just wants to tell them to
pounders yeah yeah
pounce and for sure okay well um here's
the thing people that don't have
boundaries can't hear your no um and
when they do finally hear it you can
expect them to be angry because for some
silly unknown reason to you and me they
feel entitled to your money yes and
that's ridiculous I mean what does your
husband make a year um he makes about 70
to 80 thousand okay I see you're not
telling me seven hundred thousand so I
mean you guys are just you're young
couple getting started and so the answer
is no no we're not buying airline
tickets no I'm not buying you a car no
I'm not giving you any money ever and if
our relationship is based on money then
we don't have a relationship if it's
based on me giving you money now you can
be nicer than that but that's the
message that you have to send to them
and here's the trick in the whole thing
though people that do this stuff are
excellent at making you feel guilty oh
yeah they pretty much can win the
Olympics with that yeah they're your
mother is a travel agent for guilt trips
Wow and so that's the trick you've got
it that's the only part you can control
is that you don't feel guilty and I'm
going to go ahead and just tell you
ahead of time that these people are
completely out of line that their
requests are ridiculous rude absurd
horrible and I'm not saying that so that
you become angry with your parents I'm
saying that so that you can smile nod
and say no and feel no guilt whatsoever
because no
normal human being should be asked to do
what you're doing that's just freaking
nuts okay yes I completely understand I
just and you know but don't expect them
to here no because their their their
hearing is broken yeah stuffs broken
inside of them so we pray for them we
send them to church we send them through
FPU and maybe God can change their lives
but you can't fund them you don't have
enough money you don't you know it's not
your responsibility no have you ever
read the book boundaries by dr. Henry
cloud I actually just got it in the mail
because I had a feeling that your
highlighter out get your highlighter out
and get the sticky notes it's going
you're gonna highlight the whole dadgum
book when you read the first chapter
you're gonna start cheering and laughing
because your family's in the first
chapter this is the Dave Ramsey show